le père patrick megrahi est investi
d'une nouvelle mission transformer le
sous-sol de son église
un centre communautaire juif alors du
bien le but aider les plus démunis
douze mois par année car la crise du
verglas l'an dernier a mis en lumière
dans la péninsule acadienne une pauvreté
bien plus importante que l'on pensait au
prêter des ressources primaires besoin
de bien s'habiller de bien se réchauffer
de bien se nourrir ce test les pros la
pauvreté qu'on voyait quand est-ce qu'on
est arrivé et qu'on se doutait pas que
c'était au temps présent
durant la crise le permis grand a
converti le sous-sol de son église en un
véritable camp de réfugiés pendant 12
jours les citoyens pouvaient venir se
réchauffer manger dormir et chercher un
peu de réconfort
je suis pour moi c'est une surprise des
jeunes familles abb vianney halter givry
hier après midi parce que c'était ce
qu'on aidait autant qu'on aide une
personne âgée qu'au besoin d'avoir des
drops pour rentrer une corde de bois qu
autant qu'on aide une personne coq
d'argent liquide la cinquantaine qui a
tout perdu
tel un disciple pendant la crise steve
news il permet gras il a ratissé des
centaines de maisons sans relâche
pendant des jours
steven a découvert un immense désarroi
découvert saga des gens vraiment dans le
besoin
veux veux pas tu sais que tu gardes tel
pour seul oui je sais qu il avait
plusieurs ambiances avec ça existait
mais on attend du prise
est ce qu'ils mangent trois ans bonjour
non est ce qu'il ya des enfants qui vont
à l'école japonaise année et puis qu'est
qu'à une malnutrition souper oui si
c'est son fils est devenu une forme de
méditation pour lui car après la crise
il était désemparé il s'est senti démuni
vous pouvez d'après l'église moche mais
fonderie dans cette pauvreté était
jusque là invisible entre autres parce
que personne ici une vie dans la rue
c'est une loi quand je suis arrivé comme
curé ici à des maisons abandonnées
c est lorsque la crise du verglas qu'on
a entré avec steven dans une maison la
première idée était d'envoyer vos
données pourquoi ce qu'on vient ici à
l'étape a abandonné avait du monde qui
vivait dans ce coin de pays le salaire
médian est sous la moyenne nationale
la plupart des résidents sont des
travailleurs saisonniers dans
l'industrie de la pêche
les jeunes quittent la région faute
d'emplois les entreprises ne viennent
pas s'installer ici
l'immigration est presque nul la
pauvreté est presque inévitable la
communauté s'organise tant bien que mal
parce qu'à ses yeux le gouvernement ne
semble pas s'en préoccuper
le premier ministre brandalley il ya
quelques mois a confié le dossier de la
pauvreté au ministère du tourisme ce qui
a soulevé de nombreuses critiques
divine encore trop ébranlée par la crise
de l'an dernier n'était pas retourné à
l'église depuis il était impressionné
par tous les changements
financé à même une loterie communautaire
douche laveuse sécheuse génératrice tout
pour acquérir des citoyens dans le
besoin et une cuisine qui sera
accessible plusieurs jours par semaine
le permet grâce compte livrer des repas
à la maison sur une base régulière aux
familles qui éprouvent des difficultés
question de garder contact avec eux et
nous ici on se prendre puisse avec des
choses comme ça qu'on fait c'est ce qui
ce se qui me fait à la mecque
on s'occupe de ses voisins on attend
pull miracles ici elisa céret
radio-canada la mecque